What does the word "leadership" mean for you?
Yeah, good question.
Uh, difficult one.
Leadership is motivating others in a group.
It's the one who can take control.
And guide for people in direction. It's sort of like a main idea.
Inspiration, direction, encouragement, someone can be a leader...
...of something even if they're not technically in charge of it.
But it can also be inclusive,...
...like getting people to have their own opinions.
But after all, it's to control the given situation.
Even though it's allowing people to have individual part within that.
It's more about commanding things,...
...someone taking over during the time when one is pressured...
...in a job where a lot is going on and someone needs to take control of the situation.
Leadership is controlling a group of people,...
...in terms of a team.
I think I haven't a clue.
Have to be someone very strong as a personality,...
...able to see what people need and what people strive for and help them to achieve this.
Leadership is being able to inspire people...
...to do what you think is the right thing for them to do,...
...to be able to give them that motivation and encouragement to get the job done.
Keeping people informed, obviously making the correct decisions.
A place that's well-run, a good top-down management.
Something that you have respect for.